[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka george r or spoilings
in this video we're breaking down the
game of thrones prequel house of the
dragon the new hbo show is packed with
easter eggs call backs or call forwards
and a lot of big characters that we're
going to be analyzing in this video the
entire series is based on the final
third part of fire and blood which tells
the tale of the targaryen lineage all
duking it out to take their place on the
iron throne as we know come game of
thrones the entire house was left almost
extinct and this series will be talking
about how the house of cards all came
crashing down beginning at chapter 12's
heirs of the dragon the original work
recounts all the ins and outs of the
family tree and it basically gives you
the idea if you want to be happy living
a king's life never make a pretty nice
your wife now whether so bad now whether
you've read it or not it doesn't really
matter as this breakdown will be
covering it all and after becoming an
expert on it last night what did did no
one else do the reading well i'm here to
give you the ins and outs on every
single character because of this there
might be some spoilers but i promise you
that i'll not give away any of the big
twists or deaths in this video i just
want to really use the book to add some
insight to the characters if you read it
then you'll know that it's more like a
textbook rather than being a story and
because of this it's a bit of a slug to
get through there's massive pages that
just basically list character names talk
about them for a bit and then that's it
however it actually gives the series a
big advantage as it means they can pick
certain sections and expand on them
massively they have a few plot points
that they have to stick to but beyond
that they can really go wild with it and
it leads to this being such a good first
episode
the show takes place roughly 172 years
before the death of the mad king and the
birth of daenerys we start by joining
king jaehaerys who had a reign of
prosperity and peace after the first 100
years of targaryen rule however all good
kings must come to an end and when his
health starts to fail he has to choose
an heir this is basically where the
disputes all stemmed from and this show
will be going over people vying for who
should be the rightful ruler as we learn
in this opening chapter which is
narrated by an old rhaenyra women were
completely looked over and the right to
rule often fell to the males even if
they weren't direct descendants now
djiharis and his wife queen alisan
produced 13 children with only four of
these growing to maturity marrying and
producing children of their own
unfortunately jaehaerus and alisand's
two sons died and rather than passing
the rule on to one of his daughters he
ended up choosing her cousin viserys
who's played by patty constantine you
might recognize the name viserys if
you're a game of thrones fan and dany's
brother was also called this too now
allison believed that geharis should
choose a queen and she actually fell out
with him because he refused to do it
there's a great quote in the book where
she says
a ruler needs a good head and a true
heart a [ __ ] is not essential if your
grace truly believes that women lack the
wit to rule plainly you have no further
need of me
amazing impressions there and alison
actually then flew the dragonstone on
her dragon silverwing and the two
remained apart for two years this was
known as the second quarrel but jahira
stood his ground and still refused to
budge the choice is what we see playing
out here and it very much fractures the
entire family now due to all the peace
and prosperity that the targaryens had
during this time they actually managed
to have lots and lots of children this
ended up leading to 14 potential people
who all had a right to the throne and
because of this the next ruler was
highly coveted it was actually predicted
that so many airs would lead to so much
confusion and this would eventually
cause what would be known as the dance
of the dragons now whilst this sounds
like a great little party it's actually
describing the battle for the iron
throne which led to a lot of bloodshed
we get this great quote early on and
that pretty much prophesizes everything
that's to come the only thing
that could tear down the house of the
dragon was itself oh here we also see
rhines who comes to be known as the
queen who never was she becomes somewhat
of a mentor to rhaenyra which we'll talk
about more as we get into the season now
from here we cut it the title scene
which has the targaryen banner on it
that you'll probably recognize from game
of thrones we next get a big time jump
to pick up in viserys's ninth year of
rule here we join rhaenyra riding on the
back of her dragon cyrax which was known
for its yellow scales it swoops through
king's landing and this scene is very
reminiscent of dany's attack during
season 8. this time though she's just
here to check out the view and we get
several monuments and little details in
the location firstly she passes the red
keep and you might notice that there's
some scaffolding on it because it's
still under construction next we see the
dragon pit which is still intact this is
where the houses all met during game of
thrones but it was pretty run down
whereas here it's back to its full glory
as i'm sure you can guess here captain
obvious dragons were kept here and it
was often theorized that this stunted
their growth due to keeping them
confined you also see some targaryen
banners before rhaenyra drops in i love
the way this is shot so we don't
actually see her and she drops down
evoking images of dany due to her hair
and dress we even get some notes from
game of thrones reused in this journey
to bring back good memories of the show
[Music]
[Applause]
they were all good they were all good
memories forget about the rest now here
we also meet sir harold westerling
played by graeme mctavish westerling is
a character that served in the
kingsguard back in the old days of
jaehaerys and since then he's carried
forth this idea of honor and chivalry
really upstanding bloke and next we meet
alicent alison is the hand of the king's
daughter and she ends up taking care of
viserys come the end of the entry this
is a very important part of the story as
it basically allows her to get a foot in
the door down the line now i don't want
to spoil too much but otto making sure
that she comforts him has some big
ramifications and this meeting early on
between the two characters is very
important next we travel through the
streets of king's landing and pass a
statue of a dragon i'm not 100 sure who
this is but i believe that it might be
valerian the black dread which is why
the monument is colored this way they
then go to the red keep which is nice
and red like that subscribe button after
you hit it and the thumbs up as well you
damn some of a [ __ ] now we watches
alison and rhaenyria travel through the
keep and there's that bit that you'll
recognize from that bit there's that bit
from then shout out to our editor map
for putting this all together now here
we meet her mother emma who ends up
dying in the entry along with her son
bailey the books talked about how he
lived for a day and this insult ends up
being brought into his nickname air for
a day sadly we don't really get much
with the baby and just see the pair on
the funeral pyre together it's one of
the most heartbreaking moments in game
of thrones history and watching the
entire birth scene had me squirming as
viserys's ambition ends up driving him
to choose his unborn son over his wife
now she very much shows why rhaenyra
wants to become more than just a walking
womb though it was a queen's duty back
then to give birth rhaenyra sees
firsthand what her mother's death was
caused by all in the service of trying
to have a male heir i also think she's a
bit angry how this unborn child has more
right to the throne than she does
because at the moment it's shrouding his
baby and might not even be a male we see
that emma has been through a lot and
discovered that she's lost many children
from here we could have the small
council looking exactly the same as how
it did in the original series here we
see lord corliss valerian played by
steve tucson you can't catch his
seahorse crest on his chest and his
house ended up building the largest navy
in the world they also gained a vast
fortune that made them even richer than
the lannisters you also get this very
important line here a man called cragus
drejo dreja styled himself the prince
admiral of this triarchy they call him
the crab feeder i think the crab feeder
is gonna be one of the big characters
this season and he was teased out in the
trailer he basically tied his victims to
wooden pyres that were stuck in the sand
and allowed the tides to come in so that
the crabs could feast on them we also
see otto here and he can catch his hand
of the king badge which of course also
popped up in the main show now rhaenyra
comes in and viz calls her his cupbearer
this pulls directly from the book and in
that we learn that she was given this
role at the age of eight the passage
says a table attorney and a court that
the king was seldom seen without his
daughter this passage also discusses how
she was trained to ride dragons at the
age of seven showing how many years
she's had experience of this you also
see lord lymon beesberry the master of
coin and he brings up how damon is
absent now daemon pretty much embodies
the saying of how whenever a targaryen
is born that the gods toss a coin he's
described in the burke as being cruel
and ruthless and they discuss how he cut
the hands off of thieves which we
actually see playing out in this entry
odaiman's the younger brother of the
king and he possesses the true blood of
the dragon viz never had a loving son
and this made him believe that he should
be the rightful heir however his brother
completely overlooks him and at one
point he caused a lot of issues with his
mistress miseria she's played by sonia
mizuno who you might recognize from devs
in ex machina he's nicknamed misery and
will probably play a big part in things
going forward a damon makes one hell of
an entrance and the first time we meet
him he's sat in the iron throne this is
clearly symbolizing his quest to sit
there officially and it sums up the
entire character in this opening shot of
him the original work had it as a throne
with a staircase of swords leading up to
it but the first series turned that down
thus these guys had to keep in line with
that too but they kind of do build the
sword staircase merging the series and
book together now if you're picking up
on some sexual tension here then hey you
might be on to something now he has
brought her a gift namely some valerian
steel this medal is so strong that when
it's forged into his sword it can stay
sharp forever like my dad jokes
now we get to alison and rhaenyria
sitting going through the history books
besides some weirwood the faces on them
were carved by the children of the
forest and they ended up having to flee
north once the first men came to the
continent and started a war these trees
were later worshiped by the first men
and they were meant to be shrines for
the gods of the forest we hear the
mention of the name nymeria a sort of
warrior princess that could end up
inspiring the direction that they go
with rhaenyria she rips at a page from
the book showing she's got no chill when
it comes to tradition this of course
also fits in with a woman sitting on the
iron throne and [ __ ] the sun baby a
queen is coming soon now we could've is
getting seen too due to a cut on his
back he then says this line it's a small
cut from sitting the throne it's nothing
this was actually something that was the
case with a chair and the kings had to
sit in a certain position to avoid
getting cut by the sharp blades on it we
even see this at the end when the king
cuts his finger due to the blade on the
armrest the blood on the throne is of
course symbolic and it's very much a
metaphor for the bloodshed that's about
to come now as for the wound on his back
i'm not 100 sure what this is and we
even had some talk in the heavy spoilers
office that it could be greyscale
whether it is or not i don't know but i
think it's put in place to show that the
king's health is failing after a tender
moment with his wife in which she says
this is the last time the stakes that
this is the last chance for a male heir
or planted in his mind sadly we know
that it would have been a boy but due to
his death the heirs all line up to stake
their claim now we could to the night
and see damon and his forces clearing up
the streets before the tournament begins
it's very much done as an act of terror
to show the peasants who's in charge and
it cements what kind of king that damon
would be damon is of course a play on
the word demon and he's introduced in a
paragraph that describes him carrying
out these cruel acts it says he slits
the noses of thieves chop it off of our
words that unfortunately i can't say
because it gets you demonetized on
youtube and all round he just does what
he wants we see it all play out here and
the book also describes him as being
someone who frequents wine sinks
gambling pits and the brothels which is
where he meets maziria the raid is super
violent and i love the costume design on
damon's helmet it's shaped like a dragon
with the head at the top and the wings
around his face the raid causes a lot of
issues and it very much splits the sides
that support him potentially becoming
the heir he clearly makes an enemy of
otto and proper does him later on when
he takes the favor of alison at the
games god damn the disrespect
now you also get a mention of lady ria
who in the book comes from the house of
royce damon didn't want to marry her and
he completely detests having her as his
wife however they did have a house
solidarity due to her being the heir to
the ancient castle of runestone damon
much prefers the misery that he has in
the brothels which leads to him publicly
trying to have a relationship with
maziria we catch it with her getting
banged and i heard she was looking for a
doctor who appreciated that she was
bigger on the inside
i thought my jokes were bad
next we see a tournament playing out
similar the one that featured early on
in game of thrones whereas that
introduced the mountain here we meet the
knight kristen cole he becomes somewhat
of a love interest for the young
princess and it's likely gonna cause a
love triangle with him and her uncle now
the book cites this as being an event
that saw damon and kristen going head to
head with a ladder taking the win it's
described as being a humiliation for him
with kristin knocking dark sister from
damon's hands with his weapon star now
this is riffing on the tournament of
maiden pool which was held when viserys
took his ascension here it's put in
place to welcome his new son and it's
supposed to be a day of celebration that
sadly ends in tragedy feel really bad
for viserys as he genuinely was a nice
king that looked after his people he
wanted nothing more than to carry on the
prior king's legacy and to create a
dominion of peace and prosperity however
due to all the airs that were created
under this it made it impossible and
much like how the joust was one of the
last happy moments in the original got
this likely will be too now here we meet
a baratheon an ancestor of robert who
would go on to become the king in the
first season he was a bloody said was a
great guy skewed by a ball and i don't
mean me when i say it was a ball
that actually was a really good
impression of i'm proud of that one now
they just kind of seem to push the
events together as kristin took the
favor of ryneria when she was seven
which bit weird that mate so yeah glad
they avoided that here with it taking
place much later in the timeline sadly
the celebration is cut short with emma
going through a lot of issues during her
pregnancy we hear that she's given milk
of the poppy which is a game of thrones
staple given to help ease pain we had my
guy vomiting which is what i was doing
watching this gore on the battlefield
and the pain that emma was going through
it's such a devastating way to start the
series and it shows us that this series
will not be around killing not only a
pregnant woman but also a baby you've
got to have balls to do that in the
first episode and yeah really messed up
congratulations your grace
you have a snow
even the congratulations here feels so
devastating and it rips your heart out
when you see him on the pire 2. in
targaryen fashion a dragon is used to
burn the bodies and after they were
cremated they were placed into a sept
you also get this bit
which means dragon fire in high valerian
it's also what dany of course said
during the series when she wanted stuff
to kick off and sadly this is forced
that night to discuss a new heir for the
stability of the realm daemon is put
forward but otto argues against it we
hear how he sabotaged his career and viz
also says that his brother doesn't
really have the patience to be king
oh he's listening in isn't he well they
bring up that he'd be a second maegor
who was a targaryen known for his
ferocity nicknamed mega the cruel he
lived for war and murder and the raids
would become commonplace if damon got in
a position of power the arguments here
very much set of the greens versus
blacks and this basically had people
choosing allegiances between damon and
rhaenyria the blacks were known as the
party of the princess and they supported
rhaenyria which is who we see showing up
at the end once he's named air in the
king's chamber we catch him building
models and it reminded me a lot when
dudes you know they just play with model
trains my guy has made a pretty good
recreation though and he finds some
comfort in his new girl now the pair had
lots of visits together in the box and
they grow really close in the absence of
his wife after damon's air for a day
celebration viserys calls him forth and
we see him on the throne along with his
sword blackfyre this was an ancestral
weapon of the targaryens carried by the
kings throughout their conquests this
insult really pushes the king over the
edge and it's the final straw that makes
him choose an heir damon tells him
straight and says that he's a we king
who gets preyed upon but he tells him to
return home and that rainer will become
the air instead how'd you like them
apples avis goes to a giant dragon's
skull evoking images of cersei going to
one in the main series he meets raineria
and tells her the knowledge that she
needs to be a ruler and impart in her
mind that dragons can't be controlled he
apologizes for wishing for a son whilst
she was there and we watch as she's
clothed by alison really important scene
as this friendship doesn't last too long
once the politics come into it and the
divide between the two grows more and
more as we get deeper into their history
whilst rhaenyria gets her allegiances we
see misery visiting damon and it very
much speaks to the misery that's soon to
follow
the pair leave together which ties into
the issues we were talking about before
and that will no doubt show up next time
and the king very much brings up a dream
by aegon that talks about winter coming
from the north this would of course play
into the main series and we even get a
cameo by a stark whilst he goes through
this said to be the great winter this
has the potential to wipe out the world
of men if a targaryen isn't sat on the
iron throne it's obviously setting up
the white walkers and along with what i
believe is jon snow he's said to unite
the realms against this and it's known
as the song of ice and fire might have
my analysis off there so i'm not good at
interpreting dreams so let me know below
if you have your own thoughts and
theories on who it could be but yeah
that's who i took it as how he grips the
valerian steel dagger and if this looks
familiar it's because it's the blade
that was used to kill the night king
really sets up things beautifully and it
ends this brilliant entry now as for my
thoughts on the first episode i really
enjoyed it and kind of going back to the
heat straight heat i got for saying she
hulk was mid i think this is how you
kickstart a series it's got a lot of big
moments in it introduces some intriguing
characters has progression and also
feels like they put all they could into
making sure that this was something
memorable have to say i was someone who
felt a bit disappointed with season 8 of
game of thrones yes sir i know there's
not that many of us and uh yeah even
after buying the 4k setter we watched
them last year it definitely felt like a
low point that kind of ruined all the
goodwill that people had for the series
however something about that theme
playing up seeing the dragon swooping
through king's landing it all brought
back the feeling of why i fell in love
with the show in the first place the
prequel did such a great job of
instantly placing us back into that
world that it's difficult not to admire
it even though it's all new characters
you can see how their characteristics
would carry over to their ancestors and
it's really well thought out and put
together like i said i think the book is
pretty basic in its storytelling with it
being used more as a way to describe all
the different houses but they really
brought to life and made me appreciate
the original text in a way that i never
really had before the first episode was
a great way to kick things off and i
can't wait to see what happens next time
the lord of the rings show has a lot to
do to match this and it's going to be
interesting to see who comes out on top
in this game of clones anyway that's the
video save the worst pun to last but i
hope you enjoyed it i'd obviously love
to hear your thoughts below and if
there's anything we missed or that you
feel should be talking about more then
drop it below also probably made a lot
of mistakes as well so uh yeah the
comments section's yours do your worst
now we already in competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on the screen right now
said that to you then message us on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out our breakdown of she-hulk
which will be linked on screen right now
lots of cool easter eggs in it things
that call back to the comics and yeah
i might not have had the best of time
but uh it's a video that i think is
definitely worth watching if not then
thanks for sending through this one i
hope to see you on the next one take
care peace
[Music]